several members of our audience have
three parents I looked into it for
example first up check this out this
person this person's a combination of
Seth Rogen Kevin Smith and host of
Mythbusters Adam Savage
[Applause]
next check this guy out
[Music]
this is the son of Jerry Garcia Mark
Marin and Bobby from Sons of Anarchy
here's a combination of DJ Jazzy Jeff
Whoopi Goldberg and Orko
next up the son of louis c.k Rob Reider
and wooly Willy
[Applause]
okay whatever I guess let me get here's
the daughter of Jane the Virgin America
Ferrara and Mario Lopez next is the son
of Wolverine president Chester hey
Arthur and the Boston Celtics mascot
next is a combination of Manny from
moderns family Lea delaria from orange
is the new black and Morrissey here is
the son of our own trumpet player Mark
Pender
Stewie from Family Guy
and emoji
[Applause]
this formative chorus is the daughter of
mary j blige Kerry Washington and
composer George handle
[Applause]
Oh Jerri Vivino is the son of Antonin
Scalia Sarah Palin and Steven Seagal
Andy's a mixture bobby from king of the
hill the Quaker Oats guy and the Snuggle
Bear
[Music]
and I had myself checked out it turns
out I'm the son of joel edgerton Annie
and a partially peeled orange
[Applause]
you
you